Dana's not wrong on this sometimes it
sucks because we have our favorites we
have people that we love Francis stories
how can you not like Francis and Gano
dude what matters is what's putting
butts in the seat what's on pay-per-view
tickets
for endeavor for WME for Disney for
Mickey Mouse that's all they care about
Francis is not that guy just isn't this
isn't me hating on Francis or hating on
the bfl this is very black and white
Dana's right
he's 100 right
now Brandon
what is up fam Monday morning May 22nd
what is poppin
summer's coming up for your parent for
the parents out there summer break
get your mind right right get your mind
right
all your single friends without kids
like oh we're going to Hawaii going to
Cancun pin's like cool there we go
buckle up it's game time for parents out
there it's game time you're entertaining
those little Rugrats 24 7. for a few
months
we put them in summer camp cop out put
them in summer camp my daddy just put me
at the YMCA I was there from seven to
seven
what's up what's up YMCA what's up
um a lot going on in the fight world you
had a lot going on this past weekend
this weekend not so much it's a slow
weekend if you're a fight fan but uh
hopefully you got your rocks off this
past weekend you had two big boxing
fights you had a UFC card you know so
you had a little bit going on then you
know what it would keep you afloat
there's just the drama going on
in an MMA in general it's like the Real
Housewives Of The Ultimate Fighter it's
just non-stop
um we can jump into if you want you know
what I'll start with uh I finally got
around to the Conor McGregor documentary
finally got around I think it came out
last week I'm just saying I wasn't like
ready at the minute it dropped to watch
it like I'm a serial killer doc but
either way
um I got around to it man
despite how you feel about Conor
McGregor it is so well done it is so
damn good and uh I tweeted this out
after I watched it hey it's ridiculous
but I had a sense of
sadness because that was such a great
time
it it was such a a unique time in mixed
martial arts
that I'm sad because I don't think we'll
ever see it again now I know people and
Dana says this and everybody says it's
oh when magic and bird retired it's like
oh what's the NBA going to do now or you
know when Barry Sanders retired what's
the NFL going to do now in the UFC it's
when Chuck Liddell retires what what is
the UFC going to do now I know I I get
that this is different this is different
will the UFC have more generational
talent and are they gonna have
superstars of course no doubt there's
gonna be talent that we can't even
imagine coming up in the next 10 15
years no doubt and well will they be
more skilled than Connor yeah because
it's the evolution of the game no doubt
I'm not saying that we're not gonna have
superstars in the UFC
what I'm saying is you're never gonna
have another Conor McGregor and that
makes me sad
you're just not I think he changed the
game forever and you only get those once
in a lifetime and I think why it holds
dear to my heart too is when he was
coming up I just branched out on my own
right I started with firing the kid and
then I wanted to talk fighting
specifically because you know Brian
count knows fighting less fighting but
you know sometimes he doesn't watch it
and he's not in the weeds like I am so I
want to do my own thing so that's when I
started the big brown breakdown that
just so happens when I started Connor's
rise started so it's close to my heart
because to me that was such a special
time and to cover it right and to go
through that and for a guy of Conor
McGregor's stature to
to say the things that he did and pull
it off it's just so rare because now you
know you have guys that are mimicking
Connor and saying all these things and
they're not fulfilling that right
they're not they're doing it because
they think it's what they need to do to
sell the fight Connor was the guy doing
it because that's what he truly believed
in his heart and eventually we all
believed it it was very you know when
Muhammad Ali would say these crazy
things you know and it got all this
traction you never really saw that
before and he would guarantee this and
I'll beat him here and it was very
similar to Conor McGregor though it was
a it was a magical time it was a magical
time straight up magical time I mean
when I was watching that documentary and
it was going back over the stuff I was
like oh my I mean some of it you know
because I'm covering this all the time
the fight World somebody like hold what
a special time man like when when they
showed just the weigh-ins for Connor
fight and you see Dublin flying across
the goddamn Pond and it's packed with
fans from Dublin or a press conference
and the stuff you do at the press
conference it was not we don't have this
is no disrespect to anybody in the USC
right now we do not have that right now
where it's everybody shuts down and
tunes into what one Fighter's doing we
don't have that and that's not a uh you
know no shade towards anybody in the UC
right now it was a different time and it
kind of just a different animal he's the
first to do it
it's when you look at those press
conferences I mean you're talking about
sold out man sold out and we were
hanging on every word and just remember
he's fighting Jose Aldo and grabs the
belt you're like what the f and he's
taking shots he's taking shots with Dana
and just talking all this trash not stew
and then his adversaries like remember
Jose Aldo for those of you that are
balls deep in the weeds in the fight
game Jose Aldo is a walking God man from
the WC one of the greatest 145ers of all
time and we thought kind of get started
here man there's no way dude and he said
I'm gonna knock him out I'm gonna knock
him here okay hey dude and you know like
if you lose that fight his career is
going different angles he's going a
different route he just is
and then not only does he not come out
which is so insane he knocks him out
but then we see it comes out after that
he
called it not only he called it and then
mimicked the exact same combo that he
was going to do in the locker room
before he did it out there it's just it
just you can't write this if Hollywood
wrote the Conor McGregor script they're
like no dude that would never happen
hold on he goes in the locker room
before this massive fight who it's gonna
be a nightmare of a fight for him and it
reacts aspect he talks all this trash we
know but he's never been a guy like Jose
Aldo who's a better Striker at the time
and he's gonna call his shot the exact
same shot how it's going to go down
before he goes out there that you Holly
was like no that's stupid man nobody's
gonna buy this nobody's gonna buy this
they're more likely to buy a Fast and
Furious 9 when they're launching a Dodge
Challenger into space and then shooting
out for aliens that's what the you know
that's where Hollywood there's no way it
was just a magical time man and it was a
matter of time because also
you know it's just yeah Conor McGregor's
the driving force but then you had the
khabib drama right you had to come but
the khabib drama was insane then you
have the Nate Diaz stuff going on yeah
the Chad Mendes you have just all this
stuff and then he's the first to go over
and do the Floyd Mayweather fight
which Dana recently you know will get to
the Francis and got on Dana news but
Dana was like
to go against France who goes yeah even
Anthony and Josh goes I don't want to do
those those circus I'm not doing these
Sideshow fights these circus fights
Dan's like yeah you know boxing wants
real fights it's like Dana don't forget
the reason we're down this road is
because you made the deal of Conor
McGregor Floyd Mayweather like that
started this all like that was the
Catapult to the people and Fighters and
the audience going oh they can do that
that was the first it's the biggest
fight ever just so what Conor did Back
to Connor what Connor did was just the
unimaginable but now we're so used to it
but you forget where it started when you
watch that documentary it's just such a
special time it made me sad it made me
sad because I don't think we'll have
that again it'd be tough to get it now
because guys now like when the guy says
oh
like when Connor says oh I'm gonna fight
Canelo you have uh you know Kamara Usman
say I want to fight Canelo well now it's
like yeah we could see that happening
when Connor said that that never
happened and he pulled it off it was
just it's a special time in my in my
life and I think for all MMA fans out
there now a lot of people will say man
the stuff he did the Antics he did
outside the octagon has you know given
me a different opinion on Conor McGregor
that's fine you're entitled to your
opinion but you don't get a dreamer a
Madman like Conor McGregor has to be
legit bit of craziness in that tank you
don't get a Madman inside that Octon
that dreams that big and it doesn't
spill out outside the octagon
it just it it's gonna be tough man it's
gonna be tough I'd love to see somebody
that
Savage inside.com that creative that
technical that
star driven that freaking rocket view on
his back and not spill out into his
personal life
show me an example love to see it love
to see it Michael Jordan dude he had his
vices say that right now yeah and also
tell them a different time when there
was no social media his career would be
completely different than social media
so you give me an example of a guy
that's living in the iPhone world that
doesn't have it spill over it's just not
it's not possible man it's just not yeah
the whole thing was amazing I think it
gives people a different perspective too
when you see him with his kid that
choked me up with his son god dude
that little dude has no idea no idea
it's nuts man and then I also
I think too A lot of people you have to
have respect for Connor we don't see
this with any Fighters but after he
loses khabib he comes in the back
remember khabib jumps off the octagon
it's all this Mayhem he's going for
Dylan danis and it's all this stuff and
Connor gets out of there and he's in the
back before the decision I'm sorry
before they even announce the the you
know uh the new whatever what was it was
it new no it's just for the title so
when he announced khabib was the winner
he's right in the back for the score all
that stuff before you know winner by
submission he's in the back and you see
that to Connor it's it is his life man
it was not like this gimmicky thing
where he's like oh at least I got paid
like you see him devastated
devastated you see him go in
and
I don't know if most people know this
but most of the time when you're
watching a fighter at that level even on
the prelims they're not 100 going into
the fights like you see Connor hurt his
foot going into that fight it wasn't
horrible I've seen Fighters with way
worse injuries you see in other fights
he has injuries I think it's good for
the fans to see that and him still be
able to perform you know I thought it
was interesting too his coach was saying
how the camp for khabib was a very dark
time he said he was very dark he usually
have fun there's a lot of energies this
kind of was just it was a dark the whole
the whole Camp the whole fight was dark
I was like oh that kind of made me sad
let's take a little break from all this
chatter about Francis Dana White Connor
doc I'm really rock hard all right so
listen uh touring wise I'm in La Jolla
California La Jolla comedy store that is
June 2nd through the 4th right outside
San Diego The Comedy Store in La Jolla
one of my favorite venues that kicks off
the the new tour so that starts June 2nd
through the 4th that's two shows Friday
two shows Saturday one show Sunday the
comic store La Jolla then your boys
jumping on over to Europe Belfast June
15th got one show in every city theater
run so Belfast June 15th Glasgow June
17th Manchester June 18th London June
22nd Cardiff June 23rd Dublin the car
Street Dublin one of my favorite places
ever Dublin your boy's coming June 25th
get your tickets now at thickboy.com
this episode of the shop show is brought
to you by a product that I use every
single time I do anything important
whether it's stand up podcasting
whatever it is working out your boy is
all jacked up on Happy Hippo Kratom
lately I've been using their pouches
they're the first to ever Market K dips
this is the blue Razzle Kratom extract
pouches that's right so you know I like
to dip with my nicotine but now I use a
lot of Kratom pouches my favorites Brew
wrap blue Razzle they have Wintergreen
this is the first ever to Market pouches
for Kratom this is a game changer I love
them these are 20 milligrams get you
some right now I prefer the blue Razzle
they got winter grain but your boy likes
a blue Razzle the first ever K dips
Kratom dips Come On Son but if you don't
use pouches you want gummies you want
powders you want the the Kratom shot
which I use all the time the highly
extracted Kratom shot and sour apple or
butterscotch you can get all that all
right all you got to do is go to
happyhippo.com promo code is thick with
three C's thick 23 you save 20 off
everything the K dips the gummies the
powder the shots the energy shots the
best Kratom on the planet it's happy
hippo or nothing else happyhippo.com
promo code dick23 20 off enjoy last but
not least this episode is also brought
to you by the one the only the Old
Faithful on it that's right listen your
boy's busy like a lot of my plates
sometimes too much and on it is my
savior on it helps me maintain focus in
order to function in the zone and I use
it with Alpha Brain I take the Black
Label they have it all they have the
regular Alpha Brain here's the thing you
can try Alpha Brain no risk necessary
you get your money back if you don't
love it but you're well so there's no
reason not to try it so you get the
regular Alpha Brain like everybody uses
they sold over a million bottles or I
take the Black Label that's the highly
concentrated Alpha Brain for those peeps
that have been using Alpha Brain for a
hot second need to up their game the
Black Label I swear by it and Alpha the
brain with this black label the instant
Alpha Brain the energy shot of Alpha
Brain the freaking incident you're
putting eight ounces of water the Black
Label the regular it all supports
cognitive functions including memory
mental speed and focus helps you in
mental processing it's caffeine free
helps you get that flow state that nice
Flow State all right on it also clearly
offers equipment like kettlebells steel
Club Macy's sandbag yoga mats they have
streaming Fitness on-demand Fitness so
there's no reason you have to go to the
gym anymore do it from your crib no
reason to be thick summer's coming up
it's a thick Boy Summer but cool thick
right they also offer better nutrition
for you you have them CT oils they got
protein powders protein bars Warrior
bars fish oil multivitamins gold total
gut health they got it all go to
audit.com you get temps off everything I
just told you including Alpha building
black the instant Alpha Brain the
regular Alpha Brain all the streaming
Fitness the gear go to honor.com shop 10
off now let's get back to the program
some someone just may have said but I
think it was good to see a guy at
Connor's level see how much he cares see
how much he cares it was really cool and
Dana was like man what happened you know
khabib jumped out and Connor's like I
don't give a [__] about any of that man
what are you talking about just the way
he was like with Dana you can tell they
are business partners he's not he's not
like if if I'm if in my career if Dan
came back then he's like man what
happened I'm like well sir what I think
happened you know I would be like yo can
you believe that was crazy man hey
you're still gonna let me fight again
right like Conor was like what the [__]
I don't give a [__] about all that dude
all that and all that's [__] nobody
cares I lost the fight fair and square
man that's what it is you know you're
like damn dude you realize that dude is
a different level man different level
it was so cool to see and hopefully
people appreciate it and just don't
just don't focus on the outside the
oxygon things I'm not I'm not advocating
co-signing what he's doing outside the
octagon as far as the the the Mischief
all that [__] now what you should
one of your takeaways it depends how
you're going to look at life glass half
full glass half empty what you should do
is look at what Connor's done outside
the octagon and take some notes as far
as what he was able to do with his brand
are you kidding me dude with the whiskey
with his uh the August whatever McGregor
line all that stuff the restaurants
there's a stout it's not dude
you know now you can look at it and he
can say yeah but he did all this stuff
and the diminished you know all this
crazy [__] you're missing the point
it's like this weekend Jim Brown passed
away right the great Jim Brown just so
you guys know right I'm lacrosse guy
just so you know he's a better lacrosse
player than he was a football player
Grant is playing Just against white guys
still that's all who plays lacrosse and
he dominate imagine Jim Brown as a
midfielder at Syracuse I think it was
playing lacrosse
good luck fellas so uh but point is
sorry I'm not lacrosse rat the point is
Jim Brown did so much in his career did
so I think was it eight-time uh Rush
Setter as far as the you know the the
most yards he was a rush King for eight
years in a row NFL you know Hall of
Famer did all this crazy [__] right
it was an advocate during the Civil
Rights his massive massive in that was a
face of that rallied the troops fought
against all that racism [__] all that
stuff
now
and it was also in Mars attack
my top five favorite movies he was in
Mars attack now if you want we can look
at his dark side and you can remember
Jim Brown for his Darkness there's some
horrible [__] there some bad stuff back
in the day bad stuff
you can't let that overshadow everything
man you know that's what I'm saying with
the Conor McGregor doc I saw some of the
comments like oh I I quit watching after
episode one because then you can see
Connor falls off it's like oh my God
you're missing the point man you're
missing the point
yeah all his stuff his stuff's dark gym
around stuff is dark and what's a bummer
is like some I think he's like might
have been New York Post someone was like
the day he died was like Jim Brown would
be remembered for his great football
skills but never forget like damn can
you wait a week you know
but yeah that counter stuff was cool man
it was so cool again special time for me
because as Conor was Rising
big round breakdown
was Rising then remember the only reason
I got my shot was Showtime is because
they were doing the Conor McGregor Floyd
Mayweather fight they're looking for an
MMA
analyst who would back Connor on winning
the fight
I'm your guy yeah I'm your guy tough gig
tough gig
um so that got my from the door show
time
and then you know I had a six-year
career with showtime and uh yeah man
it's just dear to my heart and watching
that dude I tear it up dude it was a
good time
since day one it was one of the most
memorable times of my life me too man
nuts yeah such a good time for us such a
good time Dublin too like going to
Dublin dude going to Dublin and I'm
wearing uh I wish you would come this
time Jim when you're on the Paris to
Korea yeah [__] too
um I wish I would go to yeah no we're in
Dublin
um June 25th uh the car street or some
[__] like that when uh Dublin uh on the
25th Obama team up with Mac life out
there oh hell yeah again these guys are
great yeah yeah
if it's uh one show only that's a Sunday
the car the car Street
see me sick man yeah Dublin's favorite
place I've ever been yeah dude probably
top two
because I felt because every like uh you
go to uh uh the UK uh my tour starts on
the 15th this is the last time I don't
know six years ago but when I went
um
so we start in Belfast which is Ireland
I don't I don't know can that's where it
gets spicy but but Belfast is Ireland
but I it's weird right because you can't
use the same flag yeah it's Northern
Northern Ireland okay guys yeah it's
dicey man I don't know the ins and outs
when I put up the Ireland flag somebody
like how dare you I'm like hey man I I
don't know the politics there dude I'm
just trying to do my thing man that's
cool bro be cool bro but uh yeah we
start in Belfast then it's Glasgow
Manchester London Cardiff Dublin here's
the thing and I'm gonna get outside
London and Cardiff and Manchester and
all that but those those big cities I
felt like I was in just a different city
in America basically with some weird
accents like same restaurant same shops
for the most part uh I like like the old
history so I need to get out right
but I'm in Dublin there wasn't a place I
could go that mimics America I felt for
the first time like I was somewhere I've
never been
it was so dope can you remember after we
got done with the shows there and we
went to uh that bar across the street
that was the oldest bar in a lot of
history there they still had bullet
holes from the Civil War it was nuts now
and I was like I was starving like we
have Chris I'm like what was that like
chicken or like no they call Chris
potato chips
and they shut down the bar and let us
stay the and the I think Patty Houlihan
was saying like they don't do this for
many people at all yes right but he
stayed there as long as he wanted to
stay there the owner and treat us like
freaking like gold it was amazing I made
a mistake but I refused to apologize for
it I'm gonna do the same thing when I'm
there I put black currant in my Guinness
and there was an article written about
you the next day next day or a day or
two yeah put that in your drink hey man
again I don't know you guys politics I
know tasty drink when I see one it was
tasty oh my God that's good best thing
yeah apparently Simon yay which I was
like hey this makes me gay
fill it up fill it up
yeah but that was a special time man
yeah man special special time point is
that Conor McGregor Doc is amazing
amazing it's dear to my heart but I'm
sure it's dared a lot of people's hearts
like we're not the only ones that went
through that chin
no everyone loved the rise of Conor it
was amazing
and the ups and downs got kind of crazy
but that's what's dope yeah like I like
the ups and downs uh listen I don't like
the you know him slapping that old guy
in the Box no I don't I'm not I'm not
condoning that yeah I'm saying I like
the ups and downs the
the the hostility towards khabib that
khabib had towards him the [__] talking
Jose Otto him even thrown the dolly
I like that nobody really got hurt I
like that he's yeah he's oh oh is he
insane yeah dude yeah yeah you got to be
a little bit to be a dreamer you got to
be a little bit batshit crazy dude you
gotta be a little different than
everybody else and not only was he
completely different than any fighter
we've ever seen but he thought tooth and
nail from nothing
to become
the single-handedly most powerful
fighter to ever compete in the UFC
even to this day it's not even remotely
close name a fighter who's your
favorites your Mount Rushmore hoyce
Gracie Chuck Liddell Matt Hughes GSP
style Bender style Bender uh Anderson
Silva uh Brock Lesnar
none of them hold a candle to Conor
McGregor and the influence and power
that he had over Dana White in the UFC
you when you watch the doc you realize
they are partners
everybody else
is just a subcontracted fighter Connor
you can see in this doc they are
partners
it's insane dude it will never be done
again he changed the game forever you've
got to respect that
take your bias out all the you know the
Antics he's done outside and all that I
get it that comes with the territory I
can forgive a lot of that stuff because
what he did was so [__] special
that's why I always say I'm a counter
dick right
have to be but that guy at the time like
we took the risk right doing all our
things
special [__] time man and it's never
going to happen again
it's just not now when I made that uh
tweet uh sugar Shawn O'Malley was like
just sit back and wait
100 now he has a lot of the same
qualities as Conor does
and can he go on like if he beats Al Joe
is he gonna be the next star hunter yeah
yeah dude he's he has a damn good chance
to be the next face of the UFC and make
more money than God for sure
but it's just it's not the same as what
Conor did it's just not
that's okay it's just different times
dude because it's been done
because it's been done and we've never
seen it before
you know yeah special special time
incredibly special yeah
man you watch it with the dog and I
think the good thing I I know how hard
Connor trains and all that I think it's
good for people to see just how
Relentless he is like we look up to the
the work ethics of uh Kobe Bryant right
like he was known for that
um certain guys in the NFL are known for
that there's guys in the MLB known for
that and then I think for Connor you
tend to forget that that's his first
love and passion because we see all this
crazy stuff you see them in the
Lamborghinis and the yachts and then you
see what a Madman he is about training
and getting better I think that's the
side people need to see because the
great ones are like that there's nobody
great there's nobody at that level that
just half-asses it and I think it's good
for people to see that the amount of
work and the pressure man nuts yeah
absolutely nuts
can't wreck it recommend it enough man
yeah
shout out to Conor McGregor
um
the the other big news besides me just
literally
deep throat and Conor McGregor for 30
minutes is uh
the Francis ganu and Dana White news uh
continues to roll on
um so it says Dana White Dana White
reacts to Francis Gun assigned with the
pfl it makes no sense to me
so I'll read what Dana said and I'll
read what
Francis said and I think my thoughts on
it might surprise you guys so
this is denim based on what I know about
the deal which is not much I bet he
knows more than we think it makes no
sense to me
you're going to pay a guy not to fight
for a year and it's only been like 18
months he's fought three times the last
three years
the day that we release them I knew
exactly what was going to happen France
wants to take zero risks doesn't want to
take any chance and he obviously didn't
want to take a chance against Jon Jones
after we saw what happened with Cyril
gone I don't blame him I think the
outcome would have been exactly the same
and I'm sure most of you do and I think
France does too and that media and the
media makes sound like I'm saying that
he's afraid of him I don't think he's
afraid of anybody it's just that he
doesn't want to take any risk
um this is important here so Dana says
pfl is going to pay this guy to train
for a boxing match that might not even
happen that they might not even be
involved in which they won't be how does
this make any sense Anthony and Josh
were called a gimmick fight this week
Francis could have done a deal here
Hunter through the kitchen sink at the
guy
I have info on that uh Francis just
thinks that he's in a position position
where he's got some Conor McGregor
Mayweather fight on his hands which he
does not MMA guys versus boxers doesn't
make any sense to me
but I think he thinks uh there's the the
monies in it I disagree I get no beef
with the pfl these guys have always been
super professional never talked any
smack you know me if I don't like you I
don't hold back I'll let you have it I'm
hearing that they're raising money right
now 280 300 million from the Middle East
I don't know who in the hell would give
them 280 I mean they're buying Bellator
so you're an organization that's burning
cash you have no ratings and selling no
tickets and you're going to raise 280
million to buy a company that's burning
cash sells no tickets does no ratings
sounds [__] absolutely genius to me
so let's just start with that chin
that's what I want you guys to do this
is my opinion on this this is why what
you do take out your let's pretend we
have no background on Dana White let's
just call Dana White
and you have no background on pfl or
Francis aganu you're going to be
um we'll call it boss b for lack of
better terms there
what boss a is saying from a business
standpoint Dana is 100 correct so if I
walk into a bank chin forget what you
know about friends to do forget the
coming from the Congo and the the mining
with the the sand and the Diamonds
whatever the hell he's doing out there
and coming across and this insane story
forget all that we're talking business
which they also don't give a [__] about
any of that
if I came to you chin and you're a big
time investor and you have a billion
dollars I go here's the thing dude so
I'm gonna sign this guy that's fought
you know fights about once a year he's
36 come off a knee injury
and we're gonna give him a portion of
the gate we're gonna guarantee him
whatever it is what do they guarantee
him [__] some millions of dollars
let's just say we're gonna guarantee him
10 million dollars a fight his opponent
gets guaranteed two million a fight
I need 300 million to get this done
you would respond and go okay well how's
things going right now are you selling
tickets no absolutely not
um okay well the only thing that would
make sense is if he's gonna fight a big
name do you have big name guys on the
roster no we don't okay
um have you done pay-per-view before
well it's really not our model but we've
done it once before how'd that go I
think we did 20 000 pay-per-view buys
that's the worst I've ever heard I know
I know but hear me out here
um we're gonna try and sign other guys
from other leagues what guys
who's becoming available soon
are they young prospects are people that
are selling tickets already no we don't
really know we're hoping for Ben
Rothwell oh is he Young no no
you know so just from a business
standpoint it's and I know Dana
obviously we know his background so it's
tough to take that out of context it's
tough not to add that into this but just
from a business standpoint
this deal is great for Francis ingano
it's great for him man they could have
said yeah we're giving 100 million
guaranteed you're all good what Francis
did was they he did a great thing for
himself
for the pfl it is a disaster I you know
and I'm not I don't want this to come
out I'm sure the the right headlines of
job hate on Francis none I love Francis
Fran's been on the show many times I
adore Francis and his agent uh Markell
absolutely [__] love those guys and
what they did is amazing that what they
did is you know history in the making
the point is is that pfl does not have
the infrastructure to carry this through
for this to be a success in any facet
whatever metrics you're looking at does
not show that this is going to turn out
well for Francis and ganu
it's just not I hope it does I hope they
get this funding I hope they get a uh an
opponent that people want to watch and
see
all signs are pointing out this is a
disaster for pfl
it's just business that's all it is I'm
not here I'm Francis I'm not here on pfl
this is very black and white the numbers
in history would show that this is not
going to work out for pfl
now Francis might get his first fight
and get paid a ton of money
but then after that it's getting a
little dicey because the funding stops
coming when they don't get the return
so by Dana White saying so you're just a
hater you don't see anybody do well
Dan's like take out however I feel about
Francis as a business he's a 36 year old
fighter that's demanding more money than
we've ever paid he's 36 coming off the
knee injury
he's 36 the guy we want him to fight
stylistically is the worst matchup
possible for him the odds are he will
lose that fight and this guy wants us to
pay him more money than anybody else
we're good
so I side with Dana on this
which is rare it's rare outside with the
guy as far as business goes if you look
at it again 36 year old fighter come off
a knee injury the guy we want him to
fight most likely he would lose that
fight just be honest with yourself he
would lose that fight
so then you sign him to this massive
deal he loses a fight
then what's next what do you do then
he's 37 by that time he's 38 what do you
do with it you invested all this money
it's not give me the face of the UFC he
already be the face of UFC heavyweight
champ was not to face the UFC it's still
not selling crazy pay-per-views so he's
assigned with this fight he loses most
likely
and you tell me that then coming up
behind there's Sergey pavlovic how's
that go
probably better than the Jon Jones fight
but
it's still you know it's not a favorable
fight for Francis he might be a slight
favorite maybe but either way tough
fight for him so then your investment
you look at Owen two
the UFC did the right thing let him go
which is insane to say yeah did we miss
out on the Jon Jones fight yeah that
sucks dude I would love to see that I'd
love for both those guys get paid now
when Dana says uh Mick Maynard threw the
kitchen sink at him
they offered and I think uh France's
coach said this Nick he said
they offered Francis eight million
dollars guaranteed plus pay-per-view to
fight Jon Jones big payday but then
after that it goes back to his normal
pay
in France like no that's why I'm trying
to get away from that normal pay
but the UFC has a business going you
don't understand we assume you're going
to lose this fight dude then after that
this is your value
and then after that we're tossing you
that what's that [__] Almeda kid the
[__] Grappler which is Johnson yeah
the nightmare it's not if you know it's
not good for Francis then Sergey Pavlich
not good for Francis so you see he's
going win or lose you're gonna make a
ton of money because the Jon Jones
fights can be massive after that it gets
dicey for you and this is what we think
you're valued at be like oh you're
disrespectful could they pay more 100
from a business standpoint what they do
that's what they're saying
Dana's not wrong on this sometimes it
sucks because we have our favorites we
have people that we love Francis stories
how can you not like Francis and Gano
dude Amazing Story Amazing Story
but at the end of the day
if you're a business you cannot care
about people's feelings and their
background in their story it does not
matter
what matters is what's putting butts in
the seat what's on pay-per-view tickets
for endeavor for WME for Disney for
Mickey Mouse that's all they care about
Francis is not that guy just isn't this
isn't me hating on Francis or hating on
the bfl or sucking Dana off has nothing
to do with that this is very black and
white Dana's right
he's 100 right
now I'm not saying he can't pay the guys
more that's not the point of this
conversation
of course you can pay more you look at
how much they made last year the biggest
year ever they get paid these guys like
a Deontay Wilder fight there's just not
they're not doing that that's a whole
different conversation for the current
model Francis does not benefit does not
work under their model that's all this
is
Dan's going pfl I don't get it and he's
right so the big payday for Francis is
not pfl that's gonna be a one-time thing
there's not enough depth on the roster
to get it done and if they do sign like
a steepe let's say castibe is almost at
the end of his contract so let's say
Stipe and John fights
uh in November math Square Garden which
is what I heard is going to happen
you think Stipe wins that fight probably
not
why not
again no disrespective I just don't
think he beats Jon Jones whoa
so then after that let's say Steepy is a
free agent so see the UFC releases some
of his contract
so the pfl signed Stipe which we've seen
now right you tell me that's gonna be
your big buyout that's gonna be the one
that does it no
who else you got
for Doom
you just go through it simple math if
you're an investor like there's no way
man there's no way
there's no way
I just it just doesn't make a ton of
sense
and then you gotta remember too for
France again we care more about Francis
than pfl at this point right we're a
Francis fans here I don't know anybody
at pfl really but with Francis he the
whole way this thing's gonna work out if
he does get that as Dana said which is
he's so I'll call in a gimmick fight
you're the one that started this dude
right the Connor Floyd you're the reason
this is this whole door has opened you
made it possible once someone sees
something happen it gives everybody else
hope it's like when that first guy to
break the five minute mile then like 50
people [__] broke it like hold up
humans can do that that's how Fighters
work hold up Connor can do that now the
flood gates are open and then Jake Paul
and Logan Paul this all started with
Dana White
so you can hate on all he wants he's the
reason all this is happening and then
gimmicks bro you don't know I got a
light Dane up a little bit here I
decided with him dude gimmicks you own
the slap Fight League
and the numerics that you use to say
it's crushing all these other leagues is
Tick Tock you're 50 years old dude you
know that's a gimmick Francis fighting
Deontay Wilder France fighting Anthony
Joshua's not a gimmick because I'll tell
you right now if Francis lands that
right hand on them they're getting
knocked out that is not a gimmick France
can win those fights or the odds are he
lands no that's not a gimmick though
that's a real [__] fight dude don't
disrespect Francis I don't like when a
guy leaves and he devalues them that's
why I don't like just say no comment you
know but that's why Dana is who he is
and he's out where he's at because he
does talk like this
comes with territory
all I'm saying is for Francis the only
way him leaving the UFC becomes a win
for him is if that box and fight comes
to fruition that's the only way this is
a good thing
the pfl is gonna be one and done it's
gonna be so much money they've thrown
their [__] in their banking on him
that's not gonna work out
I hope it does I hope I'm wrong history
would show that's not gonna work out
they don't have the infrastructure they
don't have the Stars they're not known
as a pay-per-view model they don't sell
tickets Francis was in a big ticket
seller with the monster marking machine
in the UFC what makes you think he goes
to the pfl and all those things change
with lesser competition lesser Stars
lesser names
and then you're giving the guy part of
the gate
makes no sense the only way this works
out for France besides the one fight
whoever he fights an old steepe for Doom
a Ben Rothwell something like that
that's that's the MMA side's not gonna
work out it's just not gonna work out
how this becomes a W for Francis is if
that box and fight comes to fruition
odds already loses that hopefully
doesn't but he makes all the money doing
that then MMA is just a side piece at
this point
but unfortunately
for the pfl
they're the main chick he's their main
chick he doesn't view them as the main
chick they're a side piece in this
equation
he's married to the boxing game that's
where he's going to make his money not
the pfl
goes Belly Up
too much
that's what I think
what do you got chin oh yeah so what do
you think of francis's rebuttals to this
so these are all his tweets that he but
what's your problem with me I completed
my contract was a free agent and chose
to walk away you didn't Release Me
yeah I don't think uh Dana has an issue
with that Dana's more pissed that he
didn't get the Jon Jones fight but Dana
did say like I we released them which
wasn't really the case he did fulfill
his contract right so
the only caveat with that again uh it's
hard for me to back down on this but the
just look at it from an unbiased opinion
could the UFC offer France as a contract
that trumps pfl absolutely really yeah
they have the money they have more money
you just did it yeah so could the UFC of
cap Francis if they actually want him
100 we could they when you look at how
much money they made last year the
biggest year ever they have the money to
pay Francis and John just like a Canelo
gets paid just like a Conor McGregor
gets paid for fighting Floyd Mayweather
they have that option so if they truly
thought that Francis was that guy that
could pull those numbers trust me they
would have absolutely annihilated the
pfl's contract they would they so by
releasing I think people think well he
didn't release 75's contracts like no
we're legit saying we have the
capabilities to keep this man we did not
we released him out into the wild go get
yours dude because we don't think it's
for you here anymore that's what they're
saying they're saying the only fight
that we wanted to make was the Jon Jones
after that you ain't [__] that's what
they're saying I'm not percent that's
what the UFC said
the only fight that we can make money
off of you and that people are going to
pay attention to is the Jon Jones fight
you're gonna lose that fight we just
want you for that one fight that's why
we're giving you 8 million and
pay-per-view points after that you're
just one of the guys Francis went I'm
not just one of the guys went cool walk
so he says release
in contract terms yeah he's wrong about
that the UFC could keep anybody they
want they have more money than any
organization that you know it's just up
to them who they want to keep now if
this is Connor
there's a reason Conor keeps saying I'm
a resigned with UC like he did the
interview with Ariel from his bar out
there in Dublin he's like I'll respond
with UFC 100 because he knows the UFC
knows Conor can lose a fight numbers
still show
they would never let Connor go to the
pfl not a chance yeah they would throw
the [__] entire bank account that guy
because in a business sense he backs it
up Francis doesn't
he says I'm finally getting paid and
respected and have a deal that's fair
and equal for all parties wrong
it's equal for Francis
any business guy would argue this is not
equal for pfl they're in a world of
trouble
if you ever if you ever really want that
Jon Jones fight to happen reach out to
Pete Murray pfl
that's not happening yeah it never
happens
and then Francis posted this about
uh well I'll just play it for you it's
on Twitter so it should be fine and the
idea of a Jon Jones fight seems awfully
exciting right now and John came out
tweeted said show me the money what
appeals to you most because it seems
like that would be an amazing super
fight if I'm Jon Jones and I'm home
watching this fight I start moving to
85.
you think you think that's a fight that
you'd like to put together next match
but that sure does seem exciting listen
wait hold on pause it what's he talking
about Francis and John Francis and John
so he was saying like John this John
would not want to fight Francis because
Francis would win this is way back oh
God I was gonna say Dana like super
heavy yeah
way thicker it's a while ago you look
like me when I was an alcoholic
and then I tightened it up baby thanks
psoriasis
but yeah so this is a while ago um so
that's why Francis said uh who's scared
really and uh make up your mind
but remember Dana that Dana always
Daniels The Carrot to try oh of course
the greatest of all time scared of
Francis and Fred and Johnson at home
like this [__] he's trying to
get John po he's poking the beer yeah
his promoter stop statistically there
couldn't be a worse matchup for Francis
than Jon Jones it is what it is
what Francis did to cerrogan France team
up holy [__] yeah dude
I mean it's a good post by Francis but
if you go back to that stuff that's
promoter being a promoter yeah that's
all he's doing poking the bear
does anybody in this room think Francis
beats Jon Jones
not really to be honest no I mean
obviously Francis has a shot but of
course if he lands he's the hardest
hitter I've ever seen but I don't think
ultimately he would win no I just don't
not Jeff yeah
and uh yeah John's probably getting even
better like physically into his body his
heavyweight body right now so I don't
know
I mean the cereal gone you know Francis
beats him through grappling which is
insane with one leg that shows you
Francis of savage yeah got it done by by
all means necessary
but if you watch Francis and Sarah gone
and then you watch John sergon
and Ma math doesn't really work but you
just look at the that version of John
come on dude what are we doing yeah he
looked insane is the easiest fight in
his entire career he didn't even look
that physically fit either he was just
so fat he's kind of a belly it was just
like the [__] get over here like like I
do my kid I was kid [__] get down a joke
I know it was insane like you're not
like a sophisticated crazy joke just
bullied you can't stupid [__]
so yeah it's a trip and Cyril's entire
Camp was not to get taken down
shut up
12 week Camp come here [__]
yeah Jones Gary dude give me that belt
no he's the best we got
what else you got uh so I'm sure you've
heard about this at least by now Tyson
Fury talking smack about Joe Rogan
because he said uh Joe Rogan mentioned
like if Tyson Fury and Jon Jones were in
a room
Jon Jones the one that's gonna be
walking out right it feels like an
actual fight fight not just a boxing
match yeah man like a street fight yeah
so I'll just play with my thing I saw
this and we can play it switch for the
fans
how are you gonna be bald making fun of
another bald guy I was just telling
Casey
if you're like my if you had a full set
of hair like this like you bald [__]
then it's like yeah get him when you're
bald when you find another bald guy it
doesn't work I know Infuse my favorite
combat athlete in the sport yes you've
said it times him and Connor Connor UFC
Tyson Fury uh boxing by far fear is my
[__] favorite don't go for Rogan
all right I'll play it real quick
I heard Joe Rogan say something about me
if it ain't been off all the social
media so didn't reply to at all bossy
little [__] [__] ball that a [__]
I heard him say that Jon Jones could
[__] me up if we were in the room
together I don't think so not a man born
for him mother can [__] me up in a room
on our own whatever happens in that room
I'd be walking out not a [__] problem
I mean I I do I don't I mean Rogan's
right as far as you know I mean when it
comes to hand-to-hand combat but
um you know it's not like uh an Anthony
Joshua Deontay Wilder situation with the
just straight boxes like remember fear
is a gypsy
you know he's gonna have to answer for
that wrestling Jiu Jitsu which is a
complete disaster Brogan's right but you
know you fear a little credit you know
he to me he's the greatest of all time
Grace heavy of all time if you want to
have that debate come on the show I will
destroy you who's your guy bring it on
you know what I'm saying
but yeah it again real housewives of the
UFC all this is like that drama okay
okay
it's just weird how are you gonna be
bald call another guy make fun of a guy
that was the only odd part but yeah you
make fun of his height because Tyson
Furious whatever six eight that's fine
Brogan's short of [__] that's fine the
main fun of his baldness that don't make
sense yeah
great video though and then uh so Jon
Jones responded with a tweet hey Tyson
it seemed like Joe may have struck a
nerve I'll admit there's no one touching
you in that ring right now let's not let
that confuse you with what would happen
if you stepped foot in my cage if you
ever want to put some of those questions
you got going on to rest give Dan a call
help you out
and then Tyson was like meet me in the
boxing [__] I'll play this video
quickly yeah he retracted Jones
John you're talking about me in a cage
I'm not a cage fighting mate
the best boxer actually
um so if you want to come into a boxing
ring and find me be my guest let me know
you don't have to call anybody else no
downers nobody you call me darling fight
and I'm the boss in this game me
um you're a great fighter John but you
know definitely no boxer that's for sure
all the best good luck John's like yeah
I never said boxer dude here's what's
interesting about this though
John smoked Tyson Fury in a UFC octagon
Tyson Fury smokes John in boxing ring
it's so stupid this is basically I know
it's Combat Sports that's basically like
uh that's like jokic call now you know
uh uh Jared Allen or some [__] like that
he's two completely different things of
course you're gonna dominating that it's
weird to always make that comparison yes
boxing is an aspect of mixed martial
arts but it's completely different
smaller gloves the distance the combos
completely different footwork completely
different different sport for God's
sakes
yeah so this is how John responded
yesterday Tyson says no man born from a
mother can beat me today says John can
never beat me in a box ring yeah I'm
glad we got that clarified you just
switch your beat up fast and Travis
Barker impressive yeah he's like whoa
you're not talking about UFC man I'm
kind of digging this Jon Jones and Tyson
Fury beef though yeah two of the best
going at it that's cool
and I'm glad he gave Travis Barker a
shot out there too that's cool that's my
guy
um it's also silly though right yeah and
this is this is going down like a crazy
path too because a bunch of people get
involved including Jake Paul no more
people got involved yeah
so uh let's see here
so this is Francis Agana responding to
Tyson Fury because Tyson Fury did say
like he's calling all these different
people but he didn't mention Tyson uh
Francis zagano he called out the boxers
right but you know he went to call out
whoever's free to fight so uh Francis
says I have been here the whole time
since none of these boxers want to fight
let's make it official that's what's
scary that means France says no like no
big fish on the line for boxing and like
I told you before I won that rant with
pfl Dana and Francis the only way the
Francis deal works out for him not pfl
that's a different story the only way it
works out for France if he gets that big
boxing fight from that tweet sounds like
it ain't happening it seems like yeah
Anthony Josh was like I'm good yeah and
also Tyson has so much going on in the
boxing world as far as the USIC fight is
really what boxing wants to make you
have USIC you have Dante Wilder there
you have uh Indy Ruiz who I don't know
if that's in your current events his
girlfriend hacked his Twitter and it got
weird no oh it got weird you can look
that up it got weird but um so Francis
needs to complete so many things in
boxing it'd be weird I guess he could do
it in the meantime until they figure out
the usick stuff but when I see that from
France I'm like oh [__] man nobody's
biting that's that sucks dude because
remember we thought for sure that was
gonna happen and I think Francis was so
sure that was gonna happen that's one of
the reasons he was so
kind of
confident leaving the UFC because if
sewing I guarantee if someone came to
him and said while he's in going through
the negotiation with UFC went hey just
so you know Tyson thing's never
happening dude we spoke to Tyson he said
it was fun back and forth he didn't
think it was actually going to happen
he's more focused on usig in his sport
that's never going to happen dude maybe
Dante Wilder down the road trying two
three years from now that's slight
probably five percent chance but as
you're going into negotiations with Dana
just know boxing's never happening
I would be willing to bet he would sign
with UFC
the only reasons with pfl is because
they're allowing him to box
ing's the biggest mystery in all this
that's probably not going to happen
which I [__] hate saying that
and hopefully it does though for Francis
yeah I hope it happens for him man that
would be a huge win for Francis
so Jake Paul said and I remember I
pretty I'm pretty sure Tyson Fury said
this way back like I would take Francis
in an MMA fight and a boxing fight right
back and forth so Jake Paul pretty much
said the same thing like two fight deal
uh boxing and MMA and then the one fight
would be in the UK for uh you know Tyson
and one fight would be in Africa here's
the elephant in the room
Francis needs Tyson Tyson doesn't need
Francis and that's why this sucks you
need both guys needed the same so when
Floyd and Conor fought they both needed
it Conor needed it right at the time
Floyd was older nothing really far in
boxing he that they both wanted the
fight to happen France is the only one
that wants this to happen Tyson can take
it or leave it Tyson has so much USIC is
a huge challenge to him man if you don't
know who usick is look him up he said if
he's such an entertainers nightmare he's
never lost Olympics professional unreal
smaller Gentlemen by far the most
technical heavyweight boxer we've seen
in a hot [__] second gets it done B
Anthony Joshua twice Savage
that too Francis is focused on uh but
Tyson I'm sorry Tyson Fury focus on
Tyson does not need Francis Francis
needs him so bad and it's sad dude it
sucks
yeah I don't know what's gonna happen
and here's the thing too let's say Tyson
fought usick right and lost there'd be a
rematch clause he loses that so that
you're probably looking at two years
from now once Francis has nothing else
going on in the boxing world then I
think he would entertain this right now
it's just it's just unfortunately it's
just not favorable towards Francis it's
just not sucks so do you think who's at
benefit if you look at if if Tyson
decides to do this fight against Francis
MMA boxing does it benefit Tyson no he's
the massive favorite
money-wise he make money anywhere
can Francis make money anywhere
does does does Tyson Fury's promotion
make a ton of money off that deal
is it good for pfl yeah it's great for
them he's a good Francis great for
Francis again it's very one-sided
that fight so do you think Tyson Fury
versus Francis would make more
pay-per-view buys than usik and uh Tyson
because I don't know what would happen I
don't either I don't know
the shitty thing too is we haven't seen
Francis in a hot second last time you
saw him was that lackluster fight
against Cyril gone on one leg grappling
not showcasing his boxing it'd almost be
better Francis took a fight this year
it's not happening but if I'm his
manager hey your knees good let's take a
fight against anybody that's a beautiful
has to offer starch this dude into the
[__] knockout realm up one of those
vicious uppercuts like you did uh
Overeem highlight that do a hot promo
against Francis or against fury because
right now it's like it's kind of
lukewarm right
yeah it hasn't been no he's been out for
a hot second he's not very active
okay so after Jake Paul posted this uh
there's no word from Tyson Fury at all
um and also someone kind of talked about
Jake Paul as well saying like why don't
you do the same kind of thing like two
fight deal MMA and boxing with Nate Diaz
and then Jake Paul is claiming that he
offered it to Nate in writing but Nate
didn't take it
which I don't know if that's real or not
but yeah I don't know it wouldn't even
make sense I would imagine it would 100
take an MMA fight with him yeah and just
mop the floor over them yeah it'd be an
awful fight for Jake
yeah so
that's but again Nate Nate upholds the
the kind of fighter ethics he doesn't do
the sideshow [__] that him taking a
fight with Jake Paul shows that name
takes Jake serious in boxing yeah and
MMA nobody's taking him serious
you can't he's giving him a break
basically yes but also that's Nate's not
like these other guys who will just do
whatever it takes to get the money and
the views that's why people love Nate
he's authentic yeah Nick's saying he
haven't earned a right to fight me in
MMA yeah but we will make 20 million
dollars I don't give a [__] I'm not
gonna ruin my late my brand my
reputation to fighting MMA there's no
upside for me you haven't earned that he
thinks he's earned it in boxing
alrighty um I don't think we talked
about this on this show yet but uh so
the whole UFC 291 card is amazing it's
tasty
Dana's so petty it's kind of sometimes
it's fun when people at his level of
this Petty the Francine Ghana news comes
out and Dan's like
say less you'll see 291.
Justin gaichi take my [__] money for
the BMF belt oh which that belt's so
stupid but you have yawn versus Alex
Pierre I want Alex to win that fight so
again nothing against you on I just
think Alex at 205 is there's so many fun
matchups John's had his run was champ
right not Alex do his thing eat that
uppercut for me and let's do our thing
because then Alex you know Alex versus
Jamal Hill year it's so [__] fun if
he wins
John's gonna be heavy grappling his
entire kit 21st and Bobby green take my
money Apollo Costa versus uh ikram yeah
don't know that one's weird to me that's
how you know so that just when I saw
that so he's fighting this guy we've
never heard of right he lost to homzat
he's finding a guy we've never heard of
yeah
when I saw that because we thought Paulo
Casto and Hamza was having that
middleweight I went oh we're getting
Hamza Camaro 100 percent
guaranteed get Ham's up come on now
guaranteed oh that should have been
hamzat the only reason it's not because
Hamza and Cameron's going down
guarantee it Money in the Bank
for guarantee it when you see that that
makes sense not after you have Wonder
Boy versus Michael Pierre I'll take my
money Derek Lewis uh delima fun one
Michael chiasa Kevin Holland take my
money fight is stacked son
got to do a fight campaign for that for
sure I have to
uh this is also news I guess UFC's
returning to Sydney to Australia and
they have like three different
pay-per-views set up for that that place
and the first one is going to be on
September 10th and that's supposed to be
the winner of drinkas duplexes and
Robert Whittaker facing israelitis take
my money
does anybody think the police these
beats Whitaker in here
so man then we get we get Whitaker which
I don't mind he's the best he's the best
it's kind of it'd be cool to see the
matchup between Eureka's and style
Banner especially because of the drama
yeah do I think he's gonna win yeah it's
gonna be tough
yeah yeah I think Izzy absolutely mops
the floor with two places by the way
yeah it is what it is
all right that'd be great if we can do
that in Australia too if I campaign yeah
Maybe
why not perhaps
uh and I just saw this too I don't know
how legit this is but it says the UFC's
eyeing Corey San Diego versus Umar and
imaginative who nobody wants to fight
right tough fight for Corey yeah so this
is Corey's record as of late
to fight winning streak can song your
dong and modern Vera they look great
against Cheeto selling your dog and
looked amazing I mean probably the
toughest matchup for uh
and he's like
Umar is like more ranked but he's just a
killer nobody wants to fight yeah 16-0
he's a [__] monster
God shout out to Cory look at that dude
yeah he's just starching dudes
get on Corey to get like that shot if
he's yeah if this is legit news
but um yeah um and also so Dana White
got a little bit upset at algerman
Sterling because Algerian was on his
podcast saying like yeah he's gonna take
the fight
um but he's like his body there's like
different injuries so
yeah very long ago three long ago came
out with it it's news to us we didn't
accept the fight oh snap yeah he's like
we never accepted the fight didn't came
out said that news without us accepting
that happens sometimes too right all the
time yeah all a lot of time here's the
thing for aljo and Ray and Ray you know
I love you buddy you taking the fight
they announced it that's how I know aljo
did say something later I'll show you
but no you taking the fight yeah no no
this yeah Dan's like oh no we didn't run
by you because when we run things and
that's what I announced and you're
taking the fight
and that's the August Night August 19th
in Boston against John O'Malley yep yeah
but then algae came out was like let's
do it in July yeah and then and then uh
uh sugar was like nah we're doing August
because if you're ready if you're really
ready because like I'm not ready I ain't
we'll do it in August
oh that's his body as of now but um oh
yeah so since this happened uh since Al
Joe said he says his bicep still sucks
he's gonna get an MRI and then uh his
leg is super sensitive to the touch
right now
um then Dana White kind of went off I'm
gonna went off on him on the the post
five press conference is he really well
look he's saying like yeah we I Al Joe's
kind of tough to deal with with this
kind of stuff he's always in his own way
kind of stuff and he's like
uh he just wants to put his best foot
forward in the fight Dana hey Dana you
never fought before bro I know you see a
decision like oh he didn't get knocked
out he's ready to go no dude Camp is
tough the fight is tough Henderson's
[__] time yeah and he just leg kicks
were good he just fought for you to
announce his fight without running by
him this guy is difficult no he's just
not a hundred percent dude that's how
you know he's never fought before
so this is what Dana White said about um
he had even like some reporter he's like
telling him like hey man how can you
guess who uh called me just you know to
say that this this fight's not going to
happen between uh algeman and Sean
because algeme is gonna bounce and then
someone just said Henry he gave him 100
bucks like but whatever but this is what
he said about Henry sudo
he said Henry sudo called and said
little [__] doesn't want to fight
referring to algerman so he wants to
it's not that he doesn't want of course
he wants to fight for aljo he thinks the
sugar Sean fights easier than the sahuto
fight of course he wants that fight
there's a fight he won even before
sahuto he came on this show and said
that he wanted the sugar fight he just
wants to be 100 Health yeah I don't know
why Dana White damages his product this
sells your pay-per-views this makes
money for your company why devalue the
guy
I don't get it
so this is the quote that you're talking
about
since uh yeah since Al Jimmy heard about
what Dana said he goes [__] it let's do
uh July 8th let's run in July 8th see if
you're really built like that I'll show
you what I ain't see you all this time
this is so funny dude
and uh this was also interesting so I
guess after
it was yeah one week he gained uh does
algeman Sterling after one week he
gained about a 34 pounds
yeah
that's why 45 makes sense for him he
he's been here he's not small
he's a big dude
sweating good now we are sweating good
I'm funky the fatty
or chunky the funky or funky chunky the
batty Patty funky chunky batty Patty
fatty batty
okay that was bad
it was corny funny
oh yeah he gained a ton of weight
nothing he deserves a thing just want a
massive fight yeah
that's what guys do they need a break
um so I don't know much about this
fighter but um I guess this fighter was
poor right at some point and he trained
with Colby Covington and he was just
saying how people don't know the real
Colby Covenant Colby Covington would
actually buy him food I was telling you
guys this yeah like is there actually
really good guy yeah so this guy the one
he came on food truck I was like hey can
you please not do the gimmick with me
can you just have a conversation he said
I wish I could man I think he's gotten
down this Rabbit Hole again if you asked
him she has a great house as a bank
accounts bank accounts fat if you ask
him hey when you go down this road in
hindsight and have all this hate and all
these people view you different would
you do it again I bet you'd say no
so you put Kobe comes in he's such a
great guy Cody Compton sometimes would
bring food for me at the gym people say
what they say I want to avoid him but
that guy's a great man you have to know
him to kind of know him just like me you
know at the end of the day is business
yeah he said nothing there
but so this guy's name is themba garimba
you have to know him to know him if you
know like me he's a good guy
it's probably broken English though well
whoever [__] translate help me out
here that meant nothing
uh that's Oliver hold on
what's this oh this is for later this
for Friday yeah oh this I thought was
super cool this is Ian Gary and d-rod
after the fight they're just like
smoking weed together and just chilling
and talking
and I can't play the music so
oh they're playing music yeah but I mean
yeah so you know Gary really went to
town on D Rod and it's just cool that
the fighters can do that afterwards
Dira address is so much cooler
you know he's he comes from like the
hood yeah yeah yeah oh yeah the story is
pretty like uh East L.A guy yeah Jordan
11's there
uh so we talked about this before on I
don't know which episode but before so
Israel ought to sign his ex-girlfriend
apparently she's trying to assume for
half of everything that they that he
owns since they've been together which
is so how long were they together I
don't know maybe a few years I don't
know but not seven they're not even
married that's not league but in
California Lee it's uh it's legal
marriage if you're together 70s even if
it was kids though like if you don't
like say you're not married but you have
kids it doesn't matter so if you're just
together with a girl for seven years
yeah longer in seven years your common
law marriage in California yeah I don't
know how New Zealand Works they do some
weird [__] out there shout out to New
Zealand but that's insane for her to say
that if it's true I mean I see a lot of
shootings huh she was in the gym gym
shooting where were you those days it's
crazy it's so lame does anybody support
that no no like get it girl hell no
girlfriend asked for a half dude
terrible
and I didn't know this but I oh maybe we
might have talked about a long time ago
but uh Grant Hill's daughter she's an M
like I think she's an amateur anime yeah
and she's been killing it so far
a lot of submission wins
so sort of tapping that personally debut
yep four days later I'm still in all my
daughter uh first amateur MMA fight
she's focused compose
yeah so she's doing and this is like
similar to the Jon Jones Machida choke
it's just starching yes good for her but
it's all amateur it's all amateur so far
long way to go
but still cool pretty cool yeah I didn't
think that Grant Hill's daughter would
be doing to me
that's cool
all right and I think that should be
hold on a sec
wait Joe Rogan uh responded Tyson Fury
no no I just Googled that to see oh
that's what he did yeah
respond back you already mentioned that
Jim Brown passed away unfortunately
um oh this one I wanted to show you real
quick this I'm not sure which League
this is in but apparently this is a very
rare submission it's like a reverse Alma
Plata
[Music]
I'm sick
have you ever seen that happen uh I have
um only thing we didn't cover is uh
Katie Taylor oh yeah and uh Devin Haney
yeah so Katie Taylor last that's it
sucks it's the first time you know she's
the face of boxing out there really and
uh you know she's this phenomenal female
great
great aura batter everyone loves Katie
Taylor absolutely adore Katie Taylor
here's my issue so this is a huge fight
for our first time she's fighting what
are the the crack or the hell they
caught out there first time finding out
there in Dublin and then she fights a
girl five pound dinner weight class
undefeated she wasn't set up for success
or it's such a tough fight for her
I this how you know she lost a fight
when Homer's like Conor and the the
Dublin Ireland media go it was a draw
she lost seven to three man easily
easily scored now with the lomachenko uh
Haney fight
that one's different but again
everyone's biased because you have this
older fighting lomachenko fight the
Young Buck who's gonna Dethrone him
that fight nobody got robbed I would
have liked to draw but if you go back
and watch it which I've done twice you
can see how they give it to Haney
the the judge again to hanging the I
think in the 10th and 11th should lose
his license but overall nobody got
robbed I can see how they gave it to
Haney
unpopular just very close unpopular
opinion but I think because of our bias
that Loma changes this older fighter he
needed this one he's a smaller guy
fighting a bigger younger guy you you're
rooting so hard for Lomo you're looking
to give him rounds but you can see if
you have an on by spinning how Haney won
the fight and I don't want to see a
rematch
is that it dude that's it man great
grand there's no fights as far as I know
unless something completely went on
under the radar but yeah other there's
just this which yes he wrote to the
Octagon how dare you I know that's hot
just I tried I just tried to say there's
nothing there's nothing uh Mariah kids
as far as touring goes
um toward picking back up shot the last
house had a great time at the ice house
last Friday we'll have another one Late
July but uh touring officially starts
um in The Comedy Store at La Jolla right
outside San Diego La Jolla comic store
is June 2nd through the 4th that's two
shows Friday two shows Saturday one show
Sunday and then after that jumping
across the pond I'm in Belfast Ireland
Northern Ireland is June 15th one show
only it's a theater run so one show in
every city Belfast is June 15th Glasgow
June 17th Manchester June 18th London
June 22nd Cardiff June 23rd and then
Dublin is June 25th Dublin is gonna be
the highlight of that trip I think I
absolutely love Dublin it's at the car
street uh theater there that's in Dublin
one show only on a Sunday June 25th get
your tickets right now at thickboy.com
alright I will see you soon Europe
what's popping daddy that's it love you
guys being nice to each other like
subscribe do all the fun stuff I'll see
you out there on the streets see ya